hi everyone my name is Brian and I'm
working as a software engineer at Google
and today I want to talk about something
that I really like its applications and
when I say applications its any kind of
application but in particular the one
that allow people to create things or to
do things that they were not able to do
before and there is something else that
I really like it's video games that's
why I created G develop it's an open
source and cross-platform game engine
that anyone can use to create any kind
of 2d video games why anyone because
it's an editor or a visual editor for
games where you can trade the levels of
your game and there are some kind of
visual programming I'll show an example
just just after and that allow anyone
even people that don't know how to
develop to create games and at the end
you get an html5 game that you can put
on the web or on your iOS or desktop so
here is what the software used to look
like I say used to because it's the old
version of the software that was created
or in cyberspace so it's a desktop C++
application and you can see on the right
that there is a list of objects living
in the game and in the mint in the
middle you have the the level of the
game so here it's a platformer and what
we want to do as an example is to have
when the player is stepping on the
button we want the button to be pressed
and the platform that is on the right to
go up in the air so I will show how to
do it using the visual programming so
here we go
I go to the events tab and I'm adding a
new event an event is composed of
collision and action it's a bit like a
thief then so I'm adding a new action a
new condition to check if the player is
in collision with the trigger that is
under level and if that's the case I can
add two actions so the first action
would be to change the animation of the
button so that is going to the state
where it's pressed so it's animation
number one and I mean adding another
action we
she's an action to move the platform up
in the air so I'm adding to the platform
a force on the y-axis and now if I press
play the word game is compiled to
JavaScript and running in the browser
and we can verify that the button is
working so it's kind of simple for
people that don't know up to program and
it's only based on logics no syntax to
learn or anything so few games have been
done with it
so F&E was working quite well and I did
the game on the top left with the cat
she's called lead web and check it out
but at some point I had some issues and
the litter was getting quite old I had
lots of cross-platform issues in
particular on Mac OS and Linux it wasn't
working that well and iterating on the
software was quite slow suppress press
breeding the UI was slow and limited to
all the UI components and honestly the
UX will need some henchmans and the
entree barrier for new contributors was
quite hard just press space again so it
was time for me to react and I was
wondering could the web technologies
help I've been doing a lot of react
before at work and I was like okay
that's perfect for making complex UI or
is it really can we afford super list
entries of Android development dynamic
panel 3d visualization nested dialogs
dragon drop search and all of the things
that make a real application you know
can we make ambitious application using
a react and the same goes for JavaScript
it's perfect for most applications or is
it early can we reuse an existing native
code base sure you know have if we have
advanced simulation or computation what
do we do or if we need consistent
performance well let's still let's take
a look at the code base or G develop so
there is the curve of the of the
software which is composed of two C++
classes
defining what a game is
the object and how an event is composed
of condition and actions and all the
tools that are transpiring with events
to JavaScript so that you get a running
game and on the top of this there was
all the interface done in C press press
using a toolkit called wxwidgets and
there was the interaction with the file
system so my first idea was okay let's
replace the interface with react because
I've I have an idea that it could be
better and for the file system I could
write adapters for Nijs or even in the
browser to simulate a file system we
could run this on the jas or Chrome or
browser or on electron so that we have a
browser and Egeus and we can package the
wulfing as an application and for the
central part we could use a web assembly
to expose the core classes to the
JavaScript to the rest of the JavaScript
application so a few what about web
assembly
it's a kind of low-level language that
is running in your browsers and it's a
bit like assembly meaning that it's not
a long way that you write too but more
something that you compile to and at the
end as it's an assembly like language
browsers are able to generate early fast
execution of any program that is written
in web assembly and it's running on
actually most browser in most recent
browsers including on iOS and Android
so how do we write web assembly well
there was a first the frustration was to
use Emscripten
which is what I did it's a project that
is a C++ to webassembly compiler so it
takes your C++ code base ernie through
clank a simple space compiler and
translate the output to webassembly
there are other solutions like worst or
any language that compile to web
assembly or even things like assembly
script which allow you to create web
assembly using a syntax that is really
that looks like tax script so it's rain
interesting in my case I've been using
an Krypton and I will show you the way
it works
so using Emscripten you can download the
SDK and install it and spotty it's
pretty easy and then you get you're
getting something called EMCC which is
the c++ to webassembly compiler and you
can run it on a C or simply specified
and in my case as I have a large code
base I can replace the Builder chain
that was using a classic code compiler
by EMCC
and get at the end instead of having a
binary I have a web assembly module so
fair enough we have a web assembly
module which is the code base compiled
to web assembly and we have to expose
the existing classes in C++ so that we
can use them in JavaScript so let's take
an example for example we have a class
that is an object's container so it's
think of it as the list of objects that
you've seen so we can have object and
get some object inside and then we can
have a layout it's a bit like a level
the game which is in a written from
objects container so it can have a list
of object and there is there are
additional methods like set name get
name to change the name of the river so
once we have this we want to write
bindings bindings in my case I've been
using web idea so there are a few
solutions to write these bindings using
Emscripten but in my case using web IDL
we write something that looks like that
is the interface of your C++ class so
you have to write it for all the classes
in your code base and this hello i'm
scription to generate glue code that is
that is that will be doing the bridge
between JavaScript and the web assembly
module so the way it works you have
compiled the web assembly module plus
the bindings that you have a module that
you can instantiate in the in the
JavaScript engine so on the browser or
in
yes and when it's instantiated you have
here it's called Gd you have this module
and you can start creating new classes
new new instances of your classes just
like usual javascript actually and call
the method and and it's working more or
less automatically out of the box
because the primitive types of your
functions are automatically
automatically converted so depends on
the language that you're using raw C++
or another language but in my case in
C++ the boolean are in JavaScript are
translated to boolean in C++ same for
numbers and for strings it's also more
or less automatically entered so it's
quite convenient if you are passing
objects to you to the purpose of limited
then they are converted to a pointer or
reference in C++ and you can debug more
or less using the input and output
stream in spirit are converted to
console that logs in JavaScript so with
this we have something that is running
in a browser so here is the chrome
debugger and you can see on the top
there are some output data that is
outputted but by the by to C++ code base
so it's working and then I can create a
new object and call method on it so yeah
it's working and it's quite nice to have
you know the Supra space code base you
have been writing since a few years
working in a browser there are a few
things to know first the memory
management requires care because when
you're creating a new object it's quite
interesting because it's not garbage
collected meaning meaning that if I'm
looking what this layout object is it's
actually a pointer to some place in the
web assembly memory so you can think of
the web assembly memory as a huge array
that is continuing bytes and when you're
creating a new object it's really
creating some
this memory meaning that if you just
drop the reference to the object in the
JavaScript world the webassembly object
will still be living in memory so you
have to explicitly call GD that destroy
well to destroy metal to remove this
contents from memory so in the case of
using a react or any competent based
front-end farm rock you have in the if
you creating an object when the
component is mounted you have to
remember to delete it or you can use an
effect hook if you're using a react so
another thing to know that the output
files are quite large for support for G
develop it's at least at least three
megabytes when everything is compiled to
to the web assembly module and honestly
I don't really care because I'm making a
kind of desktop application rich
application so knowing that I will
package the whole thing in an electron
application that is a few hundred
megabytes three mega megabytes more or
less at the same and something else to
know having a complete test set is
really really useful because these are
the kind of heroes that you will be
getting when something is going wrong in
the web assembly module so it's not
helpful at all and this can happen if
for example you have a wrong type for
parameter or if you forgot the parameter
then instead of getting a number of
boolean or a pointer in this precipice
world you will get and define which is
translated I guess to zero so everything
will be broken and same thing if you're
trying to use a deleted object the
native language will try to operate on
something that was removed from memory
and it will crush basically this being
said we now have something that is
walking in a browser so now my next
change was oh I can create an interface
on top of it that is as good or even
better that one I used to do in in the
in the negev who are using C press press
before so let's see how to do it again
in my case I was using
reacts and my change was to remake all
of these examples of example the context
menus three trees of objects color
Pickers lots of homes and buttons and
property grids
all of this in in the browser so I will
go through a few patterns and example
that I've been using and in the hope
that it's it's full for you
the first advice that I have is to find
a component library so for example match
our UI or reactor box or blueprint as
examples of react component libraries
and the thing I was looking at is is
there an extensive list of high quality
components because I don't want to spend
time redoing all the the basic widgets
want to build an application not to to
make a design system and is there a good
theming support and a good accessibility
and finally is there some good
documentation because the world
interface will be standing on this
library so it better be good so I went
with material UI because it was the most
library with the most extensive list of
components and its its material design
it's quite good so once I have it the
first thing I had to solve was how to
display large lists of objects and when
I say largest for example in in the case
of develop I have the list of objects
that are living on the scene of the game
and it can be a few hundred objects so
the solution here was to use
virtualization so focus on producing
react that arise and write suitable hoc
you are able to do a list to display on
screen a list that is via terrorised
that means that instead of having in the
dome in the browser and to have multiple
Dom element for every object then you
will only have the
the object that are displayed on screen
in the dome so 10 or maybe 20 objects
the way it works is that instead of
having a list of object that is just
mapping over an array you're converting
your own list to be using the list
component that is offered by Iraq
catalysed and using this property called
renderer you can say this is the
function that you will call to generate
every line that is to be displayed on
the screen and then using a rack
suitable hoc you can add the saw table
container hoc on the top of your list
and on the top of each element you're
using saw table element and you get a
list that is both the authorized and
that you can reorder using drag-and-drop
using the mouse or touch so that was the
first thing to what getting something
that is power not powerful enough but
walking well even with large lists and
big games the next thing is that I
wanted to have panels or editors that
you can resize on the screen because as
I'm doing a game engine and game editor
people want to customize their workspace
so for this I've been using a tiling
window a library which is called react
mosaic there are few different libraries
like this but this is the one I've used
and it's I mean it's working out out of
the box so check it out
then I've been trying to remake the
event CD to awesome so the event editor
it's more or less large trees a large
tree sorry with this even so an event is
composed of condition and actions but it
can also have some events it's a bit
like blocks of code in a traditional
programming language so here again the
solution was to use virtualization
precisely I've been using react saw
table 3 which is a rivalry that allow
YouTube to make it a tree of nodes that
you can reorder and
the interesting thing about this library
is that it's using a regularized under
the hood so quick quickly every note
that you see on the screen here is
actually a line in via terrorised list
and the lines that are be in between the
note it's just a fixed kind of
scaffolding that is making like that is
making the tree looks like a tree and
not a list so it's a customized version
of this that I've been using
then at some point I wanted to remake
delivery so it was actually my first the
first thing that I did and at this
moment so I want to display a live
version on the screen
so it can be composed of Android a
thousand of objects to be displayed and
at this moment you can forget the Dom
and it said go to be using WebGL well
actually have not been using WebGL
directly but something called a library
called Exige S which is the 2d rendering
library that I've been using for the
game engine so I could as well use it
for the game editor and it's super fast
and very easy to use and it's based more
or less than the flash API and there are
also options like 3d is or phaser if you
want something that is more that looks
more like your game engine sometimes
still you can still rely on the Dom for
example let's say that you have an
editor that is displaying an object here
a spaceship and you want to edit the
polygon that is displaying what what is
the hitbox for the photo spaceship so
what I've been doing here is to use SVG
SVG elements to display the polygons and
using things like pointer move up and
down you can allow the vertices of the
polygon to be dragged and dropped using
the mouse or the touch so you get
something a polygon editor that is very
easy to do architecture and to occur on
because it's all done using a react and
and it's still powerful enough for what
you want to do
sometimes things are not fast enough so
the first performance problem that you
can have is that the rendering of the
fiction is too slow at this point you
can provide the rendering so depends on
your front-end firm rock but here in the
case of react you can use the react
profiler and in this case I got an
interesting problem when I was opening
or closing a tab I had to do the wulfing
was taking like one second to be done
and when using the profiler you can see
that every it's displaying every
component that is rear-ended while you
are doing interactions and only the
component that are called on the graph
actually we rendered when you're doing
the interactions and you can see that on
the Left I had a full set of component
that was the component displaying the
project manager to the project manager
it's a bit a bit like a file explorer
and this thing was being rendered every
time I was switching to one tab to the
user even when it was hidden so the
solution was to add something like
shouldn't update or memoization so that
it's not rendered every time you're
doing an interaction so basically avoid
we're entering if you don't need to
something to notice that make sure to
meet your performance in production
because in the case of react the
development build is way slower than the
production field and something that's I
got an issue where I was dragging
dropping things and he was taking like
one second again to update but it was a
few milliseconds and so I built a
working in production and you can also
have issues with the course to
webassembly
so if you have a lot a lot of course
being negative webassembly you you're
paying the cost to go through the bridge
between javascript and web assembly
every time you're calling a function
this is less the case I think now
because I think that Firefox at least
has been optimizing this use case but if
for example you have a list of a lot of
objects and every time you're mapping on
the on the list you are calling a
function at the end it can add up
it won't be noticeable in fact in most
situation but something to remember that
sometime might be a fool to store in the
JavaScript world to cash in the
JavaScript world the result of some
computation if you want to avoid paying
the the cost to go through the bridge to
the web assembly world sometimes you're
reaching a point where you could basic
this growing a lot so a few tips on this
in my case it was because as it's an
open source project I got more
contributors and the first thing I will
I will tell is to stick to your
components so the idea is that if you
have an help button that is showing new
to open the help of the software you
might be thinking at some point okay
let's change the design of the help
button so that it's a smaller on screen
so you could add just a font sizes that
is different what I will recommend is to
make a help button at a separate
component basically to create components
for as much things as possible in other
words make a design system and try to
stick to it because also you've been
doing this this thing it will be much
faster to build new screens and
consistent screens something that I
don't know is I'm not doing any unit
tests sorry actually I do but only if
there is a bit of logic in my components
and and I think it's the case in almost
and it's it's really where you are that
I'm doing a unit test for react
component instead I'm using the I'm
creating visual stories so using for
example story book or react stylist you
can create stories that are displaying
your components outside of your
application and I found this button to
be really faster and way more powerful
to first develop components outside of
the application and so much faster
because rather than having to launch the
application and then to navigate to a
screen to see that your changes are
applied or not you just have to run
story book and go to the proper story
so it's much faster for development and
also for testing it's not automatic but
you may imagine that in the future I'm
changing I'm updating material UI or
making changes on the component I can
quickly open story book and see my
component in different state and make
sure that everything is correct it's but
it's in particularly useful for cases
like for example the hero's handling if
a component is showing in Euro that's
something that you really you've never
seen the eros when you're developing
because everything is going alright but
at least using storybook can make sure
that your components all have a new raw
state that is working the next advice
would be to use types so for example
flow or typescript my guys have been
using flow because I was more used to it
and the useful thing with types that
they will tell you when you forgot to
pass or remove a probe after refactoring
something they will elbow to completion
avoid silly mistakes and able to
document your objects always think they
are not useful when you write code but
later when you're back on some module
that you or someone else wrote a few
months ago and in other words types are
really shining when you or someone else
is coming back and refactoring some
parts of the application and remember
that after a few months you are a
stranger to your own conveys so this
being done we know I've loved the the
core of the software and an interface
that is being made on top of it and
let's see how to package this so we have
a few packaging options we could make a
PDW a because web S&P is running in the
browser so it's not an issue in my case
I've been using electrons so that I can
have access to the file system and so
because it's a game editor people like
to download an application to own it in
a way and
and having access to the file system
allowed me to avoid making something
that is only working online so we can
use the software offline and in some
case you can even embed the the
JavaScript application inside the native
application using first of all chromium
embedded framework if you have an
existing native application and after
the manpower to do it another advice
would be to build over the native API as
much as you can so for example I did two
version of the context menu one that is
using on the Left material UI context
menus that it's running in a web browser
and on the right you can see the same
context menu using actual API so you
have a really context menu and I won't
go I won't go through the code but the
idea is that instead of renderings
material UI components I can call the
external API to create this context menu
and this is something that is already
helpful for people that not a fool but
that makes the application looks like a
native application it doesn't not look
web ish and yeah we cannot know what the
result of all of this let's take a look
so this is a new application and I the
demo I'm doing here the same as before I
will be creating a button object with
two animation one when it's pressed and
one it's when it's not pressed and I
will be adding it on the screen after
renaming it to button and doing the same
thing as before adding an event so that
when the player stepping on the button
then the platform is going up in here
so that's the same moreless scimitar
face as before but all done in react
webassembly and java scripts so here i'm
choosing the player and the button and
if there is a collision between vest two
objects then i'm adding into action this
time the first one to add a force so
that the platform is going up in the air
and then another action so that the
button
is going to the state where it's pressed
so changing the the animation that how
will you do it
and when I will be pressing play same as
before the web assembly module is
compelling the wolf into JavaScript
putting in files and you get a walking
in game in a browser so yeah that's
walking at least in my definition as a
developer it's working but what our
users saying I won't be I will be honest
the first feedbacks were really bad
because but not because it was an
electronic application or built using
react or because it was web technologies
just it was just because the new version
was lacking a lot of features from the
previous one even if I did reuse the
existing code base I had to remake the
world interface around it so of course I
started by a few things and adding new
things so it was lacking features but
after a few years a few years after one
year precisely people started to say
okay there is a real difference and it's
easier to use and actually I can be more
productive using the new version
compared to the old one so it works it
was it works so well that is no even
better than the negative application why
better because I can do ultra-fast
iteration on it I can test super easily
I have a near near-perfect
cross-platform and and I have a faster
startup time it's faster and I able to
update more contributors we can try it
online
and we can even run it on the phones I
mean it's running it on a phone it's not
made for phone so you can not really use
it properly
I mean you can use it properly but it
will need some enhancement to do it but
the my point is that it's it's working
almost everywhere so with this talk my
idea was to show that actually we can do
things using react
webassembly JavaScript and all this new
front-end framework we can do things
that are not only as good as what we
used to do in the native world but we
can be more ambitious thank you
[Applause]
[Music]